- [Interviewer] All right, Kysch.
Kysch, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Kysch] New Mexico.
- [Interviewer] Which city?
- [Kysch] Albuquerque.
- [Interviewer] Albuquerque.
And tell me about your childhood,
you had both your parents growing up?
- Yeah, I had both parents.
Kind of dysfunctional upbringing,
but I made the best of it.
- [Interviewer] How was it dysfunctional?
- I was molested as a child
from my dad and grandfather.
- [Interviewer] By your dad
and your grandfather, both?
- Mhm, and I ran away when
I was 14, came out here.
And I had a modeling career for a while.
- [Interviewer] How long
did the molestation go on?
- 'Til I was 14, from as
young as I can remember.
- [Interviewer] Jesus.
- So, I was really young.
- [Interviewer] Did you say anything?
- I didn't say anything until I was 23.
And it was already too late.
But I got away from it.
- [Interviewer] And then
when you went on your own,
where did you go?
- Out here.
- [Interviewer] So you've
been in LA a long time.
- Mhm, yep.
- [Interviewer] And how
did you end up on Skid Row?
- Actually I applied for housing
and got housing through Skid Row housing.
- [Interviewer] So where
are you staying now?
- I'm right down the street,
over here on seventh.
- [Interviewer] In a tent?
- No, I have an apartment.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you have an apartment?
You're one of the few.
- Yeah (chuckles).
- [Interviewer] And do you
have children of your own?
- Mhm, I have four.
- [Interviewer] You have four.
And did you raise them?
- Three of 'em I did, one of
'em I lost my parental rights
but she reached out and
contacted me this year.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah, she found me.
- [Interviewer] Cool.
How old are your kids?
- I got a 27 year old, a 21 year old,
a 19 year old, and a 10 year old.
- [Interviewer] And so,
are you using drugs?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's your drug?
- Heroin.
- [Interviewer] Heroin.
- Mhm.
- [Interviewer] And how long
have you been using that?
- About maybe 12 years.
- [Interviewer] How do
you support yourself?
- Well, I escort sometimes.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, a lot
of the girls kind of use that
as a way to make money.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's something
guys can't do, usually.
- Yeah (chuckles).
- [Interviewer] I guess they could, but--
- Yeah, it seems to pay
the bills sometimes.
- [Interviewer] For women,
it's the go-to isn't it?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how was that?
So you do that through--
- [Kysch] Humaniplex.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Interviewer] What is that?
- [Kysch] It's an escort site.
- [Interviewer] Oh okay, I don't know.
- [Kysch] You have to be a member for it,
but it's a--
- [Interviewer] And guys
call you out of the blue?
Or they contact you?
- [Kysch] Well everybody's
a member on the site,
and like, you have your profile.
It's like a social network type of thing
but it's for escorting.
- [Interviewer] So you'll meet
a guy at an arranged address.
- [Kysch] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And do your business,
and he gives you the
money and that's that?
- [Kysch] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's safer
than walking the street, right?
- [Kysch] Oh yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is it a better
caliber of clientele than--
- [Kysch] I've never
worked on the streets so,
I've done escorting, I
stripped for a little bit
but for the most part, yeah.
I feel like the site that
I work for, it's safe.
Like I said everybody's a member on there.
I have yet to meet with
somebody who's not attractive.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So no problems?
- [Kysch] Yeah, they start at 300 an hour.
- [Interviewer] That's a
lot more than the girls
are making here on the street.
- [Kysch] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] At least
here, in this neighborhood.
- [Kysch] Yeah, there's no way
I would even work down here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
you're not gonna make
that kind of money.
- [Kysch] No, not at all.
- [Interviewer] And how many
years have you been escorting?
- Probably about five or six.
- [Interviewer] And you
were stripping as well?
- Mhm, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's the
difference, money-wise and
headache-wise, what's the
ups and downs of both?
- Well, stripping, comes
the whole lifestyle.
Bars, staying up 'til three,
four o'clock in the morning,
you know, bar lifestyle
as opposed to escorting,
you can pick your own hours, pretty much
and it's not as much work.
Definitely not as much work.
- [Interviewer] Right.
Does doing sex work kind of
get to you after a while,
or does it bother you?
Do you get depressed
or anything like that?
- Sometimes, but for the most part no.
No, I go into a mode, you know.
Kind of like, I--
- [Interviewer] I don't
mean to be judgemental,
'cause I think everybody
doing anything for money
eventually gets that feeling.
- No, the mindset, I think
it's all in the mindset,
you know, I just kind of tune out.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
helps you be resilient.
- Yeah, so it helps (chuckles).
- [Interviewer] When you were
a child, did you have like,
dreams of doing something
else with your life?
- Oh yeah, I had dreams that,
I was gonna be a cosmetic chemist,
I was gonna make makeup (laughs).
- [Interviewer] What do you think
got in the way of that ever happening?
- I think the molestation
wore my self-esteem,
you know, my self-worth.
- [Interviewer] It's hard
to maintain that self-worth
after something like that happens, right?
- Yeah, definitely, mhm.
- [Interviewer] Do you see that your life
would've been totally different
if those events had not happened?
- For sure, mhm.
- [Interviewer] I would
think that's powerful.
- Yeah, you know, I look at my kid's life,
and my kids have been fortunate,
and they're all pretty successful,
so I know that they've
had a decent upbringing,
at least I did that right (chuckles).
- [Interviewer] Yeah, (mumbles)
it stopped in your generation.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yeah, it did.
- [Interviewer] And
where do you see yourself
going from here?
Heroin's a hard drug to kick.
- I'd like to quit.
You know, it's rare
that you actually do see
people who are on heroin quit.
- [Interviewer] Very rare.
- You know, it's very rare.
But I do have hope,
I have hope that I'm
gonna get off the drugs
and do something.
I definitely want to go back to school.
- [Interviewer] Are your kids
aware that you are using?
- They're aware of my drug use, yeah.
They don't condone it.
- [Interviewer] They don't
play around with drugs?
No, no, no.
Thank god.
- [Interviewer] And what about
your parents, or your mom?
- My parents are both passed away.
- [Interviewer] Living this lifestyle,
do you think it's changed you in some way?
- Yeah but not really,
because pretty much,
it's similar, like when I was
a child and being molested,
it was like I had to
kind of tune that out.
- [Interviewer] What
are your views on love,
do you believe that love exists?
- Dysfunctional.
I mean, I'd love to say that
I got the whole love thing down pat,
but my perception of love,
I know it's not really
what love should be.
But I know that the love that
I felt for my kids is genuine.
And there's no way I could ever,
ever violate them, I don't even know
how my dad and grandfather
crossed those boundaries.
I don't get it, but you know,
as far as like in a relationship,
I don't know what a normal
relationship's like.
- [Interviewer] You
haven't seen that work out?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
that's a common story.
- What relationships
have been like for me,
five years, five years, five years.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's
a common story, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right Kysch,
thank you so much for talking with me
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- Okay, thanks.
- [Interviewer] Good luck kicking heroin.
- All right, thanks.
- [Interviewer] You'll need it.
Thank you.